foreign
[Applause]
topics then we'll drop a beat have some
fun this side we're going to come to you
first section number one for suggestion
number one what would you like a rap
about
toenails
let's let's dive into this so yeah no
because it reveals more about you
doesn't it really
well if we can't say brexit toenails it
will be
don't know why that's in my mind just
thinking about those luscious little
keratin half Moons oh yeah oh yeah
the note you ended that on made it sound
quite Asian right and that final no made
it sound like Asian toenails which
um so what type of toenails
Asian toenails it's going to be I'm
afraid that's blame red for that what
was the note that you ended are we on
The Black Keys or the white it was The
Black Keys surely for it to sound like
that yeah yeah
exactly look
you don't know red red you could be
Asian my wife his wife is there you go
when it comes to Asian toenails no one
knows more than this man
[Applause]
um middle of the room front mid back
middle will come to you next middle
front the room would you like a wrap
about mangoes
mangoes
so I did say no food but I will accept
this because it's specific enough also
the way your accent was you pronounced
it Mingos you didn't say mangoes you
said mangoes which sounds like a a
racial slur and
these [__] Mingos
um doesn't it
in Australia that sounds racist
Mingos
um are you are you a fan a connoisseur
of mangoes
you saw a video recently I'm excited
after the toenail fetish chat this is
we've gone weird now we saw a mango
video
was that the story
mangoes Chris I saw a video recently
nothing to do with man clothes
I just have an internet connection
Mancos I saw a video of mangoes Asian
toenails back at the room hello what
would you like a rap about
okay no there were two don't worry I
will accept Shrek what what makes why
were you so enthused about Shrek have
you watched pushing but person boots The
Last Wish
it's [__] good don't discount it just
because you're like Puss in Boots has a
new movie it's genuinely good don't let
your kids watch it it's too scary
um so the lady who said Shrek what do
you love about Shrek
it's just such a good movie I will
accept that it is and when that lady was
bellowing Shrek there was a gentleman
yelling something just not as loud or
vociferously what was it red-headed
girls avoiding therapy red-headed girls
avoiding therapy
foreign
[Applause]
you should be having at home with your
partner
rather than airing it in a public forum
I told you you should go red-headed
girls avoiding therapy mango videos
Asian toenails Shrek cool we've got one
suggestion left we did that so we did
these two now it's your turn what is it
gonna be
okay so okay opium dens I like Meghan
Markle is too obvious what was the other
one
mating habits of sheep
I'm not Welsh mate I'm not Welsh
feels like a Heckle there
opium dens and the mating habits of
sheep okay what happens is when I take
more than five suggestions my brain will
completely forget about three of them so
I will take it but you will have to
remind me so front row remember we've
got opium dens the mating habits of
sheep Asian toenails mango videos Shrek
and a ginger girl or red-headed girl
um avoiding therapy
so if I forget one forgive me and also
remind me and this is what we're gonna
do we're gonna make up a rap about all
those things and by we I mean us you the
lovely audience will just absorb it
through your ear holes
um
it's a lovely sound isn't it it's the
classic West Coast synth also reminds
you of a little duck it's like a little
quacky duck bread and this is what we're
we're gonna do cool
a hop skip and a jump and then I rap too
big to feel looking down at my feet
seeing toenails I'm in the Blazing Sun
Asian one coming from me B Japan you
know the fans begun he was playing on
the keys
sounding kind of racist still I think
it's fun fun looking at the Keratin
taking out my toes what do you think
about those if you chose any lady from
the Land of the Rising wiggle in my
little toe get it close to your eyes in
the Horizon coming up let the sun shine
you and I could have some fun sometime
this guy is so aroused when I'm talking
about the toes careful looking down
below you start going never so turgid I
need some tropical fruit and so I search
it I'm on YouTube yeah I really want to
try there a poor poor now maybe a papaya
it doesn't make sense to me then it
froze pick the one under my nose the
mangles chopping it up I'm feeling so
fine cross that hatch they're looking
like a porcupine did you see the video
about how to slice it it's really
amazing my advice is you've got to put
the Cuts Like a checkerboard then you
turn it inside out and I'm pretty sure
you can slice it off one simple move use
a santoku knife mango Cubes but this guy
yeah when he brings those fruit bats
shouting out like Mingo I was ever so
confused what the heck kind of wonky
like the animal from Shrek that's the
donkey we serve these moving from the
mango to Eddie Murphy waking Shrek up
early he did it more than one hey donkey
get the [__] out of my swamp he didn't
say the f word it's a Kids film Fiona
Cameron Diaz they were [__] killed I
was loving it it's what I aspire to be
as funny as a Green Ogre played by Mike
Myers but one fact you know he brings
her he takes Fiona to the therapist why
because she's Ginger he makes sure she
gets along there remember she's got the
red hair he knows her this ogre sitting
down on the couch tell me about your
childhood this is not allowed why are
you avoiding staying there in the Deep
green swamp feeling like the queen that
she wants she says my parents weren't
kind to me used to be brought up in
Regal finery but then she relapsed again
and again Shrek had to take her out of
the Opium Den and when I'm there in the
Opium I'm feeling hip hoppy I like to
get my heroine and get my poppy seeds I
take them down and I'm looking while I'm
blazing what's in the Opium Den toenails
of Asians usually because it was popular
in China That's not racist I'm not sure
showing shyness you were like oh this
rap would Sparkle but he rejected my
suggestion of the Meghan Markle I'm not
partial to rap about her used to be a
princess but then she went no I'm out of
here I'm gonna flee to the West Coast
took a ginger husband didn't you best
know he avoids a therapy as well but
he's a boy guys upset ever so annoyed he
says now I only wanted focus on the
ladies now I said this my brain would
fail me so remind me what was number six
your hands on your mouth what the [__]
did you pick a huge
of course we can do what the cow say moo
but the ones you choose they were in the
farmyard no course for alarm rutting
with the Woolen coat they were going
yeah the Sheep I would rather which you
you choose you can [__] this one harder
get them on their knees bending in the
field where a sheepskin condom that's
how they feel genuinely that's what they
made from you know I'm gonna shag this
come in the sheep's stomach like I'm
making haggis
oh